[Música]
tengo un chiste
es así es así había una fiesta de
logaritmos no estaban todos los
logaritmos logaritmos en base de 10
logaritmos en base 2 logaritmo natural
había comida bebida era un fiestón
y en un costado hay como solo solito
como mirando así medio para abajo había
una sala x
entonces va uno de los logaritmos y le
dice ven y integrarte
y él es a la x lo mira y le dice para
qué será lo mismo
bueno que yo no dije que tenía un chiste
bueno
es un chiste nada más pero este chiste a
mí me lo contaron cuando estaba
empezando mi carrera cuando estaba en
las primeras materias estaba cursando
análisis matemático y me sirvió para no
olvidarme nunca más en mi vida que la
integral de a la x vale a la x
soy nadie soy científica soy docente y
soy comediante y hace un tiempo que
vengo mezclando todo esto para comunicar
la ciencia en clave de humor pero vamos
por partes porque es importante
comunicar la ciencia es importante que
todos sepamos de ciencia no que todos
seamos científicos exitos somos
científicos es muy un infierno
o sea imagínate que el maestro de jardín
de tu hijo sea sheldon el the big bang
theory es unirnos esos niños van a
necesitar mucha terapia cuando crezcan
no es un peligro pero sí es importante
que todos entendamos de ciencia porque
porque las ciencias preguntarse cosas y
dudar y es tener pensamiento crítico
entonces si todos sabemos de ciencia
podemos juzgar mejor
la veracidad de la información que vamos
recibiendo y por qué es importante
porque utilizar el humor para comunicar
la ciencia
y porque está buenísimo es re divertido
entonces por qué no comunicar algo tan
formal como la ciencia de una manera tan
desestructurada como el humor el stand
up comedy que es lo que es lo que yo
hago es un género donde el comediante se
para en un escenario y se dirige a una
audiencia en vivo sí para que la
audiencia se ría y lo interprete se
tiene que conectar
es muy diferente al teatro muy diferente
porque porque en el teatro vos
interpreta sus personajes que no sos vos
es decir diálogos que escribió un
guionista en el stand up sus voz arriba
del escenario tienes que conectarte con
el público del público t para que el
público te entienda se identifique y se
ría
no sé cuántos de acá son docentes pero
no es muy diferente a dar una clase el
docente se tiene que parar frente a una
audiencia en vivo que pueden ser sus
alumnos los alumnos tienen que conectar
con él para entender lo que están
explicando ok no muchos docentes cuentan
chistes eso está claro pero recordemos
por un segundo quiénes son los docentes
que más nos quedaron grabados
seguramente sean un montonazo y muchos
de esos seguramente en algún momento nos
hicieron reír sí
pero que siempre fui de tomarme las
cosas con humor siempre soy de las que
se ríen de sus propias desgracias este
pasa bastante mi mamá siempre me dijo
desde que soy muy chiquitita rey de
primero de voz así le ganas de mano a
los demás
le causó gracia de alguna manera hizo
hija única bueno no importa lo trato en
terapia va a estar todo bien pero pero
siento que si me río de una desgracia o
de algo malo como que le quitó poder y
si le quitó poder gane yo cuando de
clase me pasa algo similar siendo que si
hago reír en el medio le quitó toda la
solemnidad al proceso de aprendizaje y
esto es todo mucho más simple les doy un
ejemplo yo en mis clases
yo soy profesora de química me gusta
hablar de las personas detrás de los
descubrimientos porque porque pone en
contexto todo el trabajo que costó
llegar a ese dato científico y además el
dato histórico te hace recordar mucho
mejor
el dato científico entonces en mis
clases yo tengo que hablar de la
molécula de benceno la molécula de
benceno tiene 6 átomos de carbono y 6
átomos de hidrógeno durante muchísimos
años los científicos se rompieron la
cabeza pensando cómo estaban acomodados
estos átomos en la molécula de benceno
hasta que llegó
señor que se llamaba frydrych que culé
que además de tener un apellido
especialmente diseñado para el bullying
que pule
estaba obsesionado con el benceno creo
que con esta presión no le quedó otra
que ser científico no estaba obsesionado
con el benceno entonces dicen que una
vez soñó con una serpiente que se mordía
la cola y cuando se despertó dijo claro
el benceno es cíclico
que culé que imaginación escucha una
cosa cómo hacemos para pasar de una
serpiente diabólica al benceno pero es
verdad el benceno es cíclico las bolitas
rojas que veis simbolizan a los átomos
de carbono y las bolitas celestes
simbolizan a los átomos de hidrógeno y
saber cómo están acomodados los átomos
en una molécula ayuda mucho para saber
cómo reacciona y cuáles son sus
propiedades físicas no es que los
científicos seamos todos una manga de
obsesivos con cultivos del orden y que
queramos saber siempre dónde está todo
perfectamente
bueno sí
pero en este caso ayuda un montón da un
montón de datos entonces yo me dedico a
el estándar científico que es divulgar
la ciencia mediante el humor pero qué es
lo que hace al estándar científico
diferente del estándar
convencional en el estándar como yo les
contaba antes el comediante se para
frente a una audiencia en vivo y esa
audiencia tiene que creer lo que el
comediante dice porque es la única
manera de que se rían entonces lo que yo
digo arriba de un escenario si soy
comediante tiene que ser verosímil tiene
que lucir el verdadero por ejemplo a mí
me gustan los chistes de abogados
entonces puedo pararme arriba de un
escenario decir soy abogada tengo la
edad para haber estudiado esa carrera
puedo usar perfectamente abogada ahora
no me puedo parar en un escenario y
decir soy modelo de victoria's secret
porque es claro que no me parezco a
heidi klum no sea el verosímil que se
abogada no que sea modelo de victoria's
secret en el estándar científico lo que
yo diga arriba de un escenario
no tiene que ser verosímil tiene que ser
verdad no puedo perder rigor científico
en pos de ser un poco más gracioso
y en esto aplicar el humor a la
divulgación científica es lo que
pensaron los del ministerio de ciencia y
tecnología de mi país de argentina allá
por el 2014 cuando mediante su programa
de popularización de las ciencias
crearon un curso de estándar científico
un curso dictado por un comediante y
dirigido a estudiantes de carreras de
ciencias o científicos que quieran
divulgar y contar la ciencia fuimos 30
que formamos parte de ese curso y
creamos 16 después que formamos popper
popper significa popularización entre
ciencias entre risas perdón somos una
mezcla de científicos de diferentes
áreas hay matemáticos hay físicos
biólogos químicos biofísicos bioquímicos
tenemos tenemos hasta una astrónoma que
se llama juliana que está loca
tenemos un astro más y ella se la pasa
diciendo que sabe muchísimo de estrellas
y planetas pero no tiene ni idea qué es
lo que le va a pasar a los de sagitario
en marzo
hicimos funciones en muchísimos
muchísimos lugares en centros culturales
en centros científicos en colegios
secundarios nos fuimos al interior del
país y también viajamos a algunos países
del exterior
les cuento un caso particular que me
hizo muy feliz a mí en un colegio
secundario
el 9 de julio del 2016 se celebró el 200
aniversario de la declaración de
independencia de mi país de argentina
un colegio secundario de bernal que es
un municipio que queda en el de quilmes
perdón que es un municipio que queda en
el sur de la provincia de buenos aires
decidieron hacer un acto conmemorativo
pero un poco diferente un grupo de
profesores de matemática de este colegio
me llamó y me dijo que haga reír a los
chicos conciencia yo fui a este colegio
les conté a todos la historia de los
cinco premios nobel argentinos y les
hablé también de las desigualdades que
hay entre mujeres y hombres en el ámbito
científico les hable de científicas
mujeres que quedaron olvidadas
no sé si tiene mucho que ver con la
independencia
pero sí sé que muchos de esos chicos se
fueron con la idea de cinco personas más
o menos normales más o menos comunes
como ellos que llegaron a ser premio
nobel y también quizá alguno de ellos el
día de mañana puede luchar contra estas
desigualdades que hay entre hombres y
mujeres porque fue importante para mí
bueno primero porque había muchísimos
chicos yo salía al patio y era una
alfombra de niños la que está ahí
chiquitita soy yo y el resto son todos
los niños la pasaron bastante bien
estaban bastante contentos y porque fue
importante para mí estas son dos de las
profesoras de matemáticas que
organizaron ese acto la morocha de pelo
cortito se llama alejandro misa es una
excelente profesora de matemática la
otra de pelo un poco más largo también
es una excelente profesora de
matemáticas se llama susana silveira y
es mi mamá
deja
es como muy sabido que los científicos
hablamos como difícil usamos palabras
dificilísimas para quedar por aquí
arriba y todos los demás por allá abajo
a ver por ejemplo si yo les cuento lo
que investigo ustedes me pueden
preguntar que investigas nadie vamos a
hacer esto me preguntan que investigas
nadie a la cuenta de tres está bien
1 2 3
buenos a que me lo preguntan
yo les podría contar que trabajó en el
estudio desarrollo y caracterización de
formulaciones y post o males estas capas
lipídicas pueden encapsular diferentes
tipos de macromoléculas y los complejos
así formados pueden ser utilizados no
sólo como modelo de membrana sino
también en el tratamiento de diversas
enfermedades
qué estudias qué
en cambio yo podría decirles yo
liposomas los liposomas son como unas
bolsitas microscópicas microscópicas
hechas de fosfolípidos que son
componentes naturales de las membranas
celulares dentro de estas bolsitas yo
pongo fármacos o drogas que transportó
dentro del cuerpo para el tratamiento de
algunas enfermedades
transportó drogas en el cuerpo
soy como un narcotraficante es verdad
un narcotraficante pero bueno si todo
legal y ya que estamos descuento que las
moléculas que yo encapsula en éstos
liposomas son muy políticos o sea yo
políticos nazis
para derrotar al moco
yo voy a cenar pañuelos toda mi vida
pero pero bueno el descuento otra cosa
más que suelo hacer en stand científico
algo que hago siempre arriba del
escenario
en argentina tenemos cinco premios nobel
cinco premios nobel de todos esos mi
preferido pero por lejos es césar
milstein a césar milstein le dieron un
premio nobel en 1984 por descubrir una
forma de obtener anticuerpos anticuerpos
en gran cantidad vamos por partes que
son los anticuerpos los anticuerpos son
moléculas que hay en el sistema inmune
que reconocen cosas que para el cuerpo
son malas y nos pueden enfermar cosas
raras que te pueden enfermar cosas raras
virus una bacteria cosas raras
un perro con un pulóver raro
no tiene sentido poner un suéter a un
perro ya viene con suéter como en la
lista de accesorios del perro cuando lo
compras
en buenos aires hasta le ponen zapatitos
algunos dale
bueno los anticuerpos reconocen cosas
raras que te pueden enfermar césar
milstein trabajaba estudiando cómo
funcionaban estos anticuerpos y medio de
casualidad llegó a tener un método para
obtener los puros y en gran cantidad
qué pasaba los anticuerpos los produce
una célula del sistema inmune que se
llama célula be be larga tranqui
qué descubrió la célula no se molestó
mucho por ponerle un nombre al tengo
esta célula genial que hace anticuerpos
como le pongo a darle buen ver
[Música]
capaz el hijo de este señor de los hijos
de este señor se llamaban nene nena y no
te vi venir
no sé si puedo mantener
la cosa es que esta célula vez no crece
en cultivo no se deja domesticar o si
uno la pone ahí le dice hacen de
anticuerpos no se deja no quiere
entonces que hizo césar milstein agarro
la célula ve que no se dejaba domesticar
agarro una célula que si se dejaba
domesticar
listo
por eso me gusta el descubrimiento de
césar milstein porque es simple es una
idea simple y perfecta y porque además
yo estoy segura que todos los
científicos de la época deben haber
pensado ayer así
como no lo vi
esto a mí me sirve para contar quién era
césar milstein y qué son los anticuerpos
monoclonales
hablar de ciencia en tono de humor en
clave de humor no le quita ni
credibilidad ni seriedad el humor ayuda
a derribar el mito de que la ciencia es
aburrida si uno se toma las cosas
tomarte las cosas con humor hace que te
sientas parte y si sos parte de algo es
mucho mucho más fácil entenderlo
entonces mediante chistes te vas dando
cuenta que la ciencia no es ni tan
aburrida ni tan complicada como te
fueron contando siempre
no hace falta ponerse serio para
comunicar algo que es importante gracias